حيره وفضول جداد قالبين الدنيا في اليابان
وسبب العثور على جسم غريب جديد في احد
الكهوف على الساحل كميزو
الجسم مثل ما شفته هو كره عملاقه حديديه
لونها برتقالي او يمكن اللون كده من الصدا
او قطرها واحد ونصف متر وثقيله الوزن ومثل
ما شفنا فيها
واللي لقيوها قالوا انه خبطوا عليها وطلعت
صوت بياكد انها جوفاء وبلغوا السلطات لو
حاسين انكم سمعتوا مشاهدين الخبر من قبل
ترى مو غلطانين انا نفسي حسيت بهذا الشيء
لانه من عشره ايام نقلنا خبر مو بس احنا
العالم كله يعني نقلوه اتكلم عن العثور
السكان في احد الشواطئ على كره عملاقه
ضخمه مجهوله المصدر وجات الشرطه وطوقت
المكان ومنعت الحركه وجابوا فرق هندسيه
وفرق متفجرات علشان يتطمنوا ايش هذه الكره
الناس بعد ما انتشرت الصور والمقاطع بدات
تكهناتها وبدا اللي يقول مرساوي اللي يقول
فضلات شي مرمي في البحر واللي يقول هذا
اكيد شيء فضائي واللي يقول وسيله تجسس
الصينيه والسلطات ما بتاكد ولا في شيء وفي
الاخر وبعد كثير جدا الشرطه المحليه قالت
يا جماعه ترى طلعت عوامه ارساء تحررت من
مرساها بفعل عاصفه ضخمه او انه تم سحبها
من قبل سفينه صيد كبيره وتم ازالتها من
على الشاطئ وقيل ان السلطات راح تحتفظ
فيها الفتره بعدين ترميهم الناس مستنيه
تشوف الجديده هذه ايش يعني لو عوامه ارساء
ايش اللي وداها في النهايه في الكهف
هيشوفوا
[موسيقى]